good morning carlo how are you
good morning good thanks to you
come welcome home mind thanks you
had breakfast this morning what did you
eat a I ate just a little something
I was about to have coffee week
we take it together as
never usually at school obviously in the
car for a question  of
practicality of travel times
ok and how much the feet to go to school
but about twenty minutes I always try to
leave a little earlier because in this way I
cannot stay I pray that I do
my garden
bye for a walk what do you think when you
enter school every  day but I try to
organize a little ideas on
what to do
always with a spirit of fun
I must tell the truth and you could name
one thing you love about the area where
your school is located definitely has the
ox apis that is  a sculpture of
Egyptian origin that is located right near
the school a bit of the
welcome sign that is given to me when
when I arrived at school who  is your
favorite movie star keanu reeves
probably for the matrix series is one
of the series that has me most passionate and
who is your favorite singer or group
but there is one specifically I listen to a
bit of everything is particularly folk music
ok  your hero instead but different
spiderman tex willer and my mother certainly
good what is a place you would like to
visit new york is definitely
manhattan but specifically to him and you
bye for a greeting
the camera bye bye it
will become a bit mine  garden this is
one of your favorite trees.
whole type of study and
quite good school so however
we also study things that were not the
curriculum
here it is traditional but also something
when s  and the dark card
but some crackers I just have a
snack so in the middle of the morning
nothing particular but that now you
usually leave school but always
quite late I have to tell the truth
I'm stic but not before one and a half sometimes even 14 but I hold back  a
little with my manager to
organize the work already started
with good morning
[Music]
this is our corner
very nice well to see usually you
continue to work when you come home
yes in the sense that the work is but constant
because fortunately I do the  I work
that absolutely passion and therefore
for me absolutely what do you do to
relax but I read a lot I write I am
fond of comics and therefore I
dedicate myself to reading comics
I also see a telescope I am
also passionate about astronomy a little
everything that is science and technology
and I honestly don't understand people
who get bored because there are so many and
so many things that can be done
that really the wife l  'last thing that
in my thoughts
what are your passions or even obi
outside of teaching
certainly has electronics
and computer science which is one in addition to being
a subject of teaching also
an absolute passion that I have had since I was a
child  and what is the result that
makes you most proud as a teacher
probably the many successes
my kids have had in the context
of entrepreneurship we organize
kids into real companies and
some of these become
real world entrepreneurial realities
if I could write  a situation and
motivational on the blackboard what it
would probably be if it is too late
for the past it might not be for
the future
the sense that there is always the possibility
to reorganize and find new
stimuli and new paths for one's
future
what is the most advice  important that
you would give your students to be
passionate about working for their
future and find out what bit  i the study is
a wonderful adventure
finally carlo because she became a
teacher but i probably had it
in my dna ok thanks
bye bye